l'état a belge est également visé par
des plaintes pour sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire une quarantaine de personnes
estiment que les mesures de confinement
imposé outre quiévrain était trop
restrictive arguments avancés des
restrictions qui irait à l'encontre de
plusieurs articles de la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme
principal ministères visés celui de
l'intérieur dans son locataire pieter de
crem a déclaré attendre une citation à
comparaître
on en parle avec michael verstraeten
avocats des plaignants bonjour amical
verstraete merci de répondre à nos
questions en direct sur arte france
vos clients portent plainte contre
l'état belge qui règle estime que le
confinement était trop disproportionné
pierre arnaud perotti le directeur de la
ligue des droits de l'homme mais ce qui
me lie que les mesures à était
attentatoire mais qu'elle se justifier
par la pandémie très importante et que
la convention des droits de l'homme
permet dans certains cas de limiter
temporairement un certain nombre de
libre de liberté qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez
il est vrai qu'une dans la section de
droit possibles mais rien n'avait
conditions d'abord il faut avoir une
finalité précise et objectivement qu'on
pouvait et on a des doutes en ce qui
concerne le second roman
deuxièmement il faut prendre les mesures
qui correspond bien à ce but et
troisièmement doit être une
proportionnalité en soit les mesures
prises et l'objectif des mesures et on
pense que ces conditions ne sont pas
remplies
vous avez déclaré à la rtbf qu'on aurait
dû faire des exercices qu'est ce que ça
veut dire exactement et est ce qu'on
peut faire des exercices en pleine crise
sanitaire ce que c'est pas un peu
périlleux
c'est une excellent site juridique il
faut faire il faut faire une l'exercice
conforme au droit ou voir si ces mesures
sont nécessaires
et à ce plan là il faut il faut tenir
compte que le voir ainsi les apports de
guarin s sont très faibles
il démonte seul un problème mais quand
on va dans le détail on va voir que tous
les chiffres qui sont tous les utiliser
par un point mais ce sont avant effet
pas certaines pas sûr
et à la fin il faut du recul on ne sait
presque rien de ce virus
il y en a pris des mesures qui nous on
peut douter l'efficacité mais aussi au
bureau on peut douter
alain si ces mesures sont bien conformes
au point de techniques qui sont prévus
dans dans le traité qu'est ce que vous
espérez en termes de condamnations
quelles sont les chances de voir aboutir
votre démarche
d'abord un mouvement
on va revoir toutes les mesures qui sont
prises il fasse est clair que nous
sommes pas comme des mesures en général
mais il faudra les présumés des mesures
qui sont très précis
on sait très bien qu'ils se trouvent
dans les lits de soins intensifs et on
doit prendre des mesures pour protéger
ces gens on doit pas prendre des mesures
qui limitent la droite
les autres gens il faut il faut se
diriger à la personne qui sont en danger
cette procédure est ce que peut inspirer
les citoyens d'autres pays pour
protester contre le confinement on sait
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de manifestations
anti confinement à travers l'europe ces
derniers jours oui il y avait déjà des
procédures en allemagne plusieurs
tribunaux déjà amené l'institution de
déprise il est aussi en hollande
entré maintenant de commencer une
procédure contre l'état augmentent
je sais qu'en france on est aussi sur le
point de commencer des procédures contre
l'état français
et quelle quelle est la réaction du
gouvernement belge
face à cette procédure on doit encore
attendre un peu parce que nous avons
envoyé un signe justice ce jour au
ministère de l'intérieur avec une
citation depuis 17 ans page alors on va
voir sur fourie j merci beaucoup
michael a verstraeten d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
l'un des avocats des plaignants